-Now, I thought I'd share some
of my favorite #carfails
from you guys.
Here we go.
First one's from @CTaylor8.
She said, "My dad once hired
a taxi to drive him
around the mall parking lot
because he couldn't
find his car."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-I've been there.
This one's from @brendaemily.
She says, "One night,
I was coming up on a red light
when my flip flop got stuck
so that, when I hit the brakes,
the gas pushed down."
No, "The gas pushed down, too.
I hit a truck
in front of me, panicked
& kept tugging my flip flop,
hitting him again and again."
[ Laughter and clapping ]
I'm sorry! I'm sorry!
I'm sorry!
[muffled] I'm in the trunk!
[ Chuckle ]
This one's from @Celizabeth107.
She says, "After the windshield
wipers on our family car broke,
my mom tied a string to them
and would 'pull and release'
when it rained."
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
-[Laughing]
-It was a lot of work.
This one's from @beer stat.
Yeah!
-Is that "Gimme like
beer, stat"?
Like that?
-No. Maybe like beer stat,
Both:
like beer statistics.
[ Laughter ]
He says,
"My dad owned an arcade
that specialized in slot cars
and his name was painted
on the side of his van,
so I got to spend high school
driving around in a van
that said Hot Slots on it.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @NewsomScoob.
Oh, I know.
-Oh, yeah, you know Newsom.
He says, "I was playing
'Dream On'
as loud as I could in my car.
A pebble flew up
and cracked the windshield.
For a second,
I thought Steven Tyler's voice
[ Laughter ]
broke the glass." It's like
he's that good!
[ Applause ]
[high-pitched]
♪ Dream on ♪
This one's from @KleoPotato.
-Oh.
-She says, "I was driving
down a hill one time
when my brakes stopped working.
Right at that moment,
'Highway to Hell'
came on the radio.
[ Laughter and applause ]
All I could do was laugh
and await my death."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[Laughing]
-That's just perfect, yeah.
-Oh!
-Down shift.
This one's from @allieshite.
She says, "In high school,
I had to stick a screwdriver
into a hole in the console
to put my Subaru in gear.
That's how it got named
the Screwbaru."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
[ Applause ]
-That's how it got named.
-That's how it got named. Sure.
That's a bunch of sh.
That's a bunch of shite.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Bunch of.
That is a lot of shite,
but that's from @allieshite.
-Yeah, yeah, God bless her.
The Screwbaru.
-That's how it got the name.
-That's what she told
her mom, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Ugh!
This one's from @pottsyMJ.
-Yeah.
He says, "My mom was
driving me somewhere
and stopped at a light.
She rested her forearms
on the wheel and wondered
who was 'honking so loudly?'
Turns out her breasts
were pushing her own horn!!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[Cackling]
-Wait!
[ Laughter ]
Wait!
-What?!
I don't know what's going on.
-Wait!
-This last one is
from Craig Lefferts.
He says, "I accidentally rear
ended the person in front of me
while my daughter was
in the car.
Everyone was fine,
but my daughter went around
telling people that our car
kissed another car's butt."
[ Cheering and applause ]
There you go. There's our
"Tonight Show" hashtag.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.